the danish gambit
tricky aggressive
and that's why has been chosen by many
white players
but imagine a line where we can not only
shock white opponent but in most of the
cases it is black
who get the opening advantage
[Music]
sounds interesting right
let's get started
e4
e5
d4
e captures d4
and now white plays this dangerous
gambit starting with c3
if you check the database from here
the majority of the games continue with
d capture c3 or the mood d5
where i think white is well prepared
but imagine my surprise
which is even not there in this top five
choices
and yet
completely diffuse the whole white setup
are you ready
look at this
queen to e7
and i should say what a move
because this weird queen move
can create so many problems for the
white camp
first thing first we are attacking on e4
so as i have highlighted over here
these are the most popular choices by
the way
and against each of them
black planning of campaign is very
simple
yet very deadly
so what we are up to is
we want to do a queen trail
so that
this extra pawn do count in almost all
queenless middle game
not to mention there are some cool
tricks and traps exist
in this lines as well
for example
let's start with 4th most popular choice
knight to f3
played in roughly 1400 games
and white's big idea is that after queen
captures e4
and the move bishop to e2
he want to quickly castle on the king's
side
and exploit
black major pcs on the e file
but unfortunately for white
black hit him with the first trick on
the table
yup
this killer move d3 wins the game on the
spot
as white bishop is hanging
so after the fourth sequence
queen captures d3 queen captures d3 and
bishop captures d3
we achieve our goal
removing the queen
and becoming a pawner
so that with the accurate play
this is definitely a winning position
from the opening stage
okay
let's start with the white's most of
choice
bishop to d3
defending the pawn
we will hit back in the center
with d5
whereupon queen to e2
is by far
the most popular choice
and i can't tell you how many people has
fallen for this
as after d captures e4
it doesn't matter however white
recapture
once again black quickly get a winning
position
for example let's start with queen
captures e4
which actually helps black what he wants
to do
so we are more than happy to do this
queen trade
with this forcing line
bishop to f5
queen captures e7
knight captures
e7 if the bishop moves anywhere then the
c3 pawn drops
where white will be a clear pawn down
so white has to go with this bishop
exchange
and after this
once again he cannot capture on d4 as
after knight captures d4
completely winning
with an extra pawn
so the fourth sequence continue with
g4
hitting the knight first
so that
once the knight moves
then white can capture on d4
so at first sight this looks like a
completely equal position
but nope
after black's next reply that is h5
black is almost winning in all of this
llama
white has two options
whether to move the pawn or
to protect it
if we play the move g5
then by force black wins the pawn
with the following sequence
knight to c6
knight to e2
knight to f5
bishop to e3
but after castle on the queen side
white cannot introduce the third
defender that means
a d4 pawn is a complete corner
well some of you may says
i don't need to move the pawn
where i can protect it with the move f3
whereupon black has another nice
tactical sequence
knight to c6
knight to e2
castle on the queen side
bishop to e3
and yes indeed there is no third piece
to attack on d4
but this time black has equally strong
reply
knight to d5 which by force
winning the game
the point is after bishop to f2
black can play the move knight to b4
where he has a double threat
number one
fork on c2
number two
d3 check nab the bishop and then take on
d4
well to parry both the thread white has
to play king to d2
to whom black can respawn with this very
nice move
bishop to c5
once again winning
the important d-pawn
the second option bishop captures e4 is
even
the worst choice
because after knight to f6
it doesn't matter wherever this bishop
goes
our next sequence is pretty obvious
we exchange the queen
and then take on c3
whereupon the end result is
yup we are pawn up
and although white has some pieces
developed
i don't think so with the queenless
middle game
this has been justified
so with the battery preparation it is
certainly black who is for the choice
the second most popular choice by the
white cam is to capture back with the
pawn
but i don't think so this is great as
after simple queen captures e4
white is already having some issues
as he cannot play queen to e2
as after queen exchange we get to our
familiar territory
and bishop to e2 drop the g to pawn
so by force he has to play bishop to e3
whereupon
you can choose either of this move
let's say here black first place
bishop to b4 check
and after knight to c3
indeed continue with knight to f6
okay white still cannot develop light
square bishop
so he continued with
knight to f3
and his idea is very simple
he wants to play bishop to d3 and castle
on the king side
but exactly here
black can unleash
a nice cunning move
knight to g4
so if you look at the database here
in the majority of the game white has
tried these two moves
but i'm afraid they are not enough to
save the game
for example let's start with bishop to
d3
bad move
and the reason is black has this nice
tactic on the table
knight catches e3
so if white take this knight then we can
deliver this queen jack
munching yet another pawn
so by force white has to go for the
queen tree
bishop takes e4
knight takes d1
and after rook takes d1
yup time and time again we get our goal
queenless middlegame with a clear pawn
advantage
so bishop to d3 is right out of the
equation
the second move queen to d2 is neither
good as well
because once again we can take on e3
and white really doesn't want to
exchange queen
where he is upon down
so f captures e3 what else
whereupon we can simply respond with
queen to e7
and as i have shown by the arrows
black has a very simple plan
he wants to play d5 and then reroute
this b night to the f6
and in all these instances
white backward e pawn
gives black
a good opening advantage
last but not least
what to do against the move queen
captures d4
which at first sight looks very logical
you are defending on e4 and regaining
your material back
but it has a drawback that it gives up
some tempos to the black camp
knight to c6 hitting the queen
queen to e3
and now
what else but to pressurize the e pawn
knight to f6
bishop to d3
and yup this thematic break d5
whereupon
black has already sets up a cunning
trick
well if you look at the database here
more than 350 games goes with
e captures d5
which i'm afraid a big time blunder
as black has a stunning reply
did you spot it
congratulations if you see the move
knight to e5
and after this
white is in a huge trouble
well the threat is very obvious knight
takes d3
and even after the base sequence
bishop to b5 check c6
pawn takes c6
b takes c6
yes indeed
voluntarily black has destroyed his
spawn structure on the queen side
but he has the tactical point
that is
after bishop to e2
this knight to g4 move can create
wonders for the black
camp as the knight is attacking the
queen
white has two popular choices
the first option bishop captures g4 is
absolutely bad
and i won a quick game against 2200
with the following forcing sequence
bishop captures g4
so the threat is knight to d3 check
my opponent plays knight to e2
now i renew the thread with rook to d8
so obviously enough white castle on the
king side
but after black's next reply rook to d3
more or less the game has been finished
white queen has to stay in protection
with the knight
so the only move here is
queen to e4
whereupon after black's next reply
white get rude shock
boom
[Music]
what a move
now obviously enough i think you already
see that if white foolishly take this
bishop then after knight to f3 chat
he simply lose his queen
so that is right out of the equation
and in the game my opponent indeed play
rook to e1
which in fact allow me to finish the
game very quickly
with rook to d1
after the rook exchange the dust has
been settled down
and one can easily see that
it is black who has come up with a clear
peace advantage
last but not least what happens if your
opponent continue with queen to g3
well this time around black has a nice
tactical shot
so before i move on i like you to pause
this video and find out a killer move
here
which wins on the spot
are you ready
did you find this amazing move bishop to
e6
a nice deflection move
so that if white foolishly take this
bishop
then
his king get force checkmated after the
following sequence
knight to d3 a double discover check
king to d2
now you give queen check
which by force nurse the white king in
the center
let's say king to c2
queen captures c1 king captures d3
rook to d8
king to e4 and knight to f6
and i think i should stop here
as chess engine suggests that
there is a mate in seven
something which you definitely want to
try out as an exercise
the best white can do over here is play
the move bishop to e3
but after this the sequence is very easy
yup you take on e2
knight takes e2
now you give this check
if the king goes to the d5 then queen to
d7 is a very strong reply
so by force white king has to go on f1
square
but after this
yup
the simplest continuation
knight takes e3 queen takes e3
queen takes
pawn takes
and now the string in the tail
knight takes b2
whereupon
yup indeed we have equal material on the
board
but look at the horrible pawn structure
white is having
and not so surprising
black obtain a nagging age from this
position
there is a high profile game in the
database
where black quickly get an upper hand
with the following sequence
knight to d2 happen
black plays castle on the queen side
attacking the knight
knight to d4 has been played
c5
knight to f3
but after black's next reply that is
knight to a4
i think white is already losing the plot
here
he tried rook to c1
and although engine's top choices g6
here
i like what black has done in the game
namely rook to d3
and winning important pawn
that's it guys
i hope you enjoy and learn this
high profile tricky line against the
danish gambit
remember at this point play the move
queen to e7
and it doesn't matter however white
continue
black's overall plan that is to exchange
the queen
and enter into the pawn advantage middle
game can be achieved in most of this
variation
whereupon the most important factor is
as to forget about his attacking stop
and misely try to defend his passive
position
works out very well in this lines
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care